hi i'm alvin i like to bake brownies at
home
and today i'm going to be making
brownies with 20 ingredients
10 ingredients and two ingredients i
think it's going to be fun to see how
the ingredient amount affects the
brownies
so let's get to it first up the 20
ingredient brownie
this recipe i'm starting with brown
sugar
some granulated sugar three sticks of
butter
and mixing them with a hand mixer until
it's nice and incorporated
then i'm adding some eggs some salt
and some vanilla extract and again
mixing until
everybody becomes friends and the
mixture is nice and silky and smooth and
just looks really good yeah i really
like the texture of this
sugar egg stuff next up i'm adding some
melted dark chocolate which i just
microwaved until it was
melted and that's just also going to get
mixed in
with the egg and sugar mixture and
become this really glossy
smooth chocolaty ribbony stuff that just
it already smells really great in here
next adding some all-purpose flour some
dutch processed cocoa powder which is
essentially a really really good version
of cocoa powder
because it really tastes like intense
chocolate so if you can find it i think
it's great after it's all
sort of mixed make sure to scrape down
the sides so any of that residue is
folded back in
and after that i'm going to fold in some
chopped up semi-sweet chocolate
just to add a lot of texture and have
these pockets of
chocolate that'll be nice and gooey once
the brownie is baked
all right now i'm going to transfer it
to a pretty large
pan lined with some parchment paper to
prevent sticking
i'm just going to spread it out push it
toward the edges make sure that
everything is
as even as i can get it and then this is
going to go into the oven
and bake at 350 degrees for about 25
minutes
while that's baking i'm going to make
the cream cheese topping so i'm mixing
cream cheese
some mascarpone cheese which really adds
a nice and rich flavor using a hand
mixer to sort of get those two combined
first
then i'm adding some sugar some vanilla
and mixing again until this is all one
really smooth
creamy mixture then one egg
oh just you know make sure you don't get
any shell some milk
and combine this until everything is
nice and liquid there's no lumps again
make sure to scrape down the sides too
because sometimes cream cheese can get
stuck
and we really don't want any lumps in
this mixture because we want everything
to be really smooth and delicious
so after those 25 minutes are up take
out the brownies and pour this mixture
directly on top
of the brownies it should flatten out
and even out pretty easily
and return those back into the oven for
another 30 minutes
so this is what it looks like after it's
finished baking and cooled for a couple
of hours
now i'm making a ganache for the top so
this is just some chocolate
and some really hot heavy cream and some
salt
i'm slowly stirring this with a spoon
because i don't want any air bubbles in
this and it takes a while but eventually
it'll become this really shiny and
glossy chocolate ganache that
i just kind of want to eat that but
first it has to go on top of the
brownies so i'm going to pour
the ganache evenly over the brownies
and i may or may not have definitely
licked the bowl
after that off screen but you guys don't
even see that
making sure that it's spread all even
one trick that i also like to use at the
very end is to kind of shake it until it
all evens out
until it almost looks like a mirror
which you can see yourself which is kind
of cool
after that it goes back in the fridge
for a couple of hours until it's
completely cool and the 20th ingredient
is going to be some flaky
sea salt which i think really adds a
nice visual and a textural touch
i like to trim the edges off of this one
because that's an excuse for me to eat
all of the trimmings and two i think it
just makes for a prettier presentation
especially that i'm going to give all
these brownies to my friends so
i like to trim all these off you can see
it's taking a little bit but hey these
are some really really thick and
fudgy ones so it's definitely worth the
effort
the layers look great it's pretty
awesome and this is the 20
ingredient brownie with a cream cheese
topping and a chocolate ganache
on top i'm going to be tasting these at
the very end so stick around
all right moving on next up is the 10
ingredient brownie first i'm starting
with some semi-sweet chocolate that has
been chopped
adding some dutch processed cocoa powder
some espresso powder
a couple sticks of unsalted butter and
just kind of giving that a nice mix
until this really rich chocolate looking
mixture comes together oh yeah
that's looking really nice shiny next a
couple of eggs
some granulated sugar brown sugar
kosher salt vanilla extract
and mixing that again with a hand mixer
until the eggs and the sugar sort of
whip together and become
super fluffy this takes a couple of
minutes but
it's pretty cool because the mixture
goes from kind of this yellow brown
sludge looking thing to these nice pale
golden
yellow fluffy cloud ribbon things
yeah those look nice and after that
pouring in that nice chocolate mixture
that we've made before
and i'm just gonna bob ross and jackson
pollock all over it because
that's that's how the chocolate came out
and then slowly mixing that in with a
hand mixer again
wow jeez that looks that looks great and
then just mixing that
until it's all combined and everybody
just having a good time
for the dry ingredients i'm sifting
together some flour and
just to make sure that there aren't any
lumps and then folding it in with a
spatula
because i don't want to overwork the
flour too much i beat the crap out of
the
eggs and the sugar and the butter like
it owed me money so i don't want to do
that to the flour as well
this batter is going to go directly into
the same pan lined with parchment
i just want to make sure i get every
little bit of there spreading that
around
it's really smooth and easy to work with
so it's pretty nice this is the tasty
101 ultimate brownies recipe so it's a
really good one
this goes in an oven at 350 degrees for
20 minutes
first then i take it out and bang it on
the counter so that you get these nice
cracks that appear at the top
so after it's cooled it looks like this
i've taken it out of the pan
and i really want to trim the edges
again because
these are snacks that i'm going to eat
myself and the rest go with my friends
so i'm going to trim these edges
and cut these up into nice squares so
that you can see the texture inside
it's really soft and really fluffy as
you can see the top has this nice
crackle topping to it
and these are the 10 ingredient brownies
from the tasty 101
series which is fantastic last but not
least the two ingredient brownies
so these start with four eggs which i'm
going to use the hand mixture
to beat until they're really really
fluffy
thank you hand mixer for saving me a lot
of physical stress because that would be
a lot of work once you're really fluffy
i'm pouring in a cup of melted nutella
or any chocolate hazelnut spread you can
find around it's just melted in the
microwave until it's warm
and it can i'm just you know doing a
little painting over the eggs again
because i don't know how to get stuff
out of a
container mixing it again until the
mixture becomes nice
and sort of cohesive it looks a little
bit liquidy at this point
that's totally fine pour this onto a
square baking pan again lined with
parchment paper for easy removal
and this goes into 350 degree oven for
about 25 minutes
after they're done and cooled they look
like this so they shrink down a little
bit mostly because the eggs have a lot
of air in them
but this yeah definitely looks like
brownies and this is optional but i like
to frost them with some more additional
melted nutella just because i think it
adds up some extra flavor
covers up any cracks or crackles that
might have appeared
and it just makes it look prettier
overall so
technically it's still two ingredients
because we already used nutella so
please don't
yell at me in the comments and now we're
going to cut it into
some pieces i may or may not have gotten
nutella all over my kitchen by doing it
this way but i think the end result
looks
really really delicious look at that
texture it's pretty awesome
and these are the two ingredient
brownies with just nutella and eggs
it's pretty awesome okay so time to
taste the 20 ingredient one
was really decadent and really rich the
brownie was fudgy the cream cheese added
a nice
creamy touch that sort of matched the
chocolate well
and the chocolate ganache on the top
really just sealed the deal and made it
just a really great dessert-like brownie
the ten ingredient one was very soft it
was really fudgy because all the eggs
and the sugar being whipped together
and it's just your solid overall brownie
the two ingredient one was really
interesting it was almost like a
chocolate sponge cake that was a little
bit dense
the nutella on the top definitely added
some extra sugar
and some extra oomph to it that made it
feel special which was pretty cool
fun fact i'm actually allergic to
nutella but i had to eat this for
science
don't worry i'm okay so how much does
the ingredient amount affect the end
result
i think brownies are something where you
get out what you put in the 10
ingredient one is your standard
amazing solid normal brownie recipe the
20 ingredient one
really was just an elevated more amped
up filled in version
of your normal brownie it would have
been great without the cream cheese and
the ganache but i think with those it
kind of takes it to another level
then two ingredient one is actually
something i was very surprised by
even though it has no flour it's
literally just nutella and eggs
it came together to form something that
tasted very close to brownie
if you didn't tell me i don't think that
would have been only two ingredients
honestly if you want to make brownies
any of these recipes are fantastic if
you want to go all out
go for 20 go for 30 even there's a lot
of things you can do with it
if you want something that's just quick
and you only have nutella and eggs lying
around
you can make brownies too if you just
want a solid brownie that hits all those
notes the ten and gritty one is
fantastic
if you make the two ingredient ones make
sure that the people you're serving
aren't allergic to nutella
otherwise they might sue you and on that
note have a good one happy baking i'll
see you guys next time
[Music]
[Music]
you